[Music]
my next guest starts on the popular ABC
series happy endings let's take a look
okay it is time for one guy comes over I
want you to look him right in the eye
and I want you to say to him what's your
best price and when he gives it to you I
want you to say thank you and then I
want you to just calmly walk out can you
do that yes yes I can
so ladies what is your best price did
you want the two door or the this is not
a joke you you injured yourself did it
happen doing that stunt that we just saw
no oh okay
that was impressive that was really
funny another our stunt my son's double
Megan did that and she actually had to
go to hospital Oh
so but she's totally fine and she did a
great job making me like funny right
yeah worth it yeah Megan so what else so
what happened to you I was hurt actually
in a scene I was shooting with Damon
Wayans Jr where I had to slap him over
and over again yeah and so they thought
he would be hurt in fact I was hurt
badly I get hurt all the time but what
how would you get hurt slapping someone
is I inflame the hey good question I
inflame my rotator cuff I did it over
and over again and so basically I've had
this sling for two weeks
that's so weird you sounds like you you
slapped him like 50 times he's fine
absolutely this makes him seem so macho
I was clapping the air in fairness in
front of him and I managed to hurt
myself doing basically nothing are you
in pain right now yes you have any meds
ready well they gave me vicodin which I
have had to take at night and sometimes
during the day I'm not on it now did you
bring any
I'm okay but it's strange to just be on
vicodin during the day like it's it's
not great yeah a little weird that's
okay someone does think it's great of
course but to a point to a point let's
be sensible here before we go your I
know you've got this injury how long you
be in the sling for a two weeks
okay all right can you pretty much do is
it making your life impossible is it can
you pretty much do everything you want
to do with that I mean sort of it's
impacted slightly my ability to flirt
because it's strange to kind of sidle up
to someone you know and try to be sexy
and then you've got this going give a
little of that you give a little try to
flip your hair it's just a minute always
comes back to this guy yeah it's hard
oh you've been dancing with that thing
yeah I mean you got to get down when you
can and when you need to but it's hard
again you've got it's like just kind of
feature it and like let it
[Laughter]
very nice oh you'll be fine
[Applause]